[موسيقى]
ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد لا نقاش ملفنا
اسانيد لم يبقى على الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والبرلمانيه في تركيا سوى اسبوع واحد
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان على راس حزب
العداله والتنميه في مواجهه مع ثلاثه
مرشحين ابرزهم مرشحوا التحالف السداسي
كمالك
رئيسه حزب الشعب الجمهوري استطلاعات الراي
تتنبا باقبال قياسي للناخبين وتظهر ان
المنافسه على السباق الانتخابي هذه المره
ستكون قويه حتى انه من المتوقع ان تشهد
جوله ثانيه بعد اسبوعين الرئيس اردوغان
يواجه منافسه قويه من المعارضه وتحديات
غير مسبوقه قد تنهي عهده الذي دام لعقدين
خاصه بعد تراجع شعبيته وفق استطلاعات
الرايه وذلك لعده اسباب منها الازمه
الاقتصاديه قضايا الفساد تعامل حكومه
اردوغان مع زلزل المدمر في فبراير الماضي
عدا عن ان نحو
الاتراك هم من الشباب ولم يعرفوا في
حياتهم قائدا لتركيا غيره لذلك يرون في
الانتخابات فرصه لجلب قائد جديد لبلادهم
اردوغان من جهته رد على هذه التحديات بانه
ملا خلال الفتره السابقه او انها ملئه
بالانجازات الصناعيه كاطلاق اول سياره
كهربائيه تركيه وبتدشين اول سفينه هجوميه
برمائيه وتسليم اول شحنه من الغاز الطبيعي
لمحطه بحريه اما عن منافس اردوغان المرشحه
رئاسي كمالك
المدعوم من تحالف المعارضه المكون من سته
احزاب فهو وفق استطلاعات الراي يتقدم
بفارقا ضئيل واكد انه اذا فاز بهذه
الانتخابات المرتقبه سيجلب الحريه
والديمقراطيه الى تركيا مهما كلف الامر
بحسب قوله
نتابع هذا الموضوع بالنقاش مع ضيوفنا من
اسطنبول جواد جرك المحلل السياسي اهلا بك
ومن اسطنبول كذلك طه عوده الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي اهلا بكم ضيوفي الكرام اسمحالي ان
ابدا معك سيد جواد سيد جواد البعض عنوان
ومنهم في الواقع ساندي تايمز
عنونه هل هي نهايه حقبه اردوغان هل هي
نهايه حكم اردوغان في داخل التركي كيف
يمكن الاجابه عن هكذا سؤال وهكذا عنوان
تحيه لك ولضيفكم ولمشاهدينا الكرام
كل تركيا حبس انفاسها
للاسبوع القادم الانتخابات في هذه المره
حقيقه انتخابات تاريخيه بالنسبه الى
سؤالكم انه رئيس اردوغان في اقوى وقته لم
يقدر يصل الى
51% في هذه المره قضيته صعبه جدا كما
تفضلت انه جيل جديد اكثره معارض لي حكم
اردوغان وايضا تراجع شعبيتي بسبب تضخم
والملف الاقتصادي الفاشل
وقضيه الزلزال
وبقاء عجزهم عن المساعدات بشكل في مستوى
مطلوب عده قضايا اثرت انه تراجعت شعبيته
بشكل واضح هؤلاء طبعا يعرفون حزب العداله
والرئيس اردوغان انهم يقدرون في الجوله
الاولى ان يصلون الى 51% في المقابل هناك
معارضه موحده قويه جدا في هذه المره
توحدوا كما كانوا في الانتخابات المحليه
الاخيره بصراحه في هذه المره الحظ مع
المعارضه اكثر كما تشير الاستطلاعات الراي
هنا في تركيا سيطاها ما رايك في هذا
الكلام هل تتفق مع ضيفي بان المعارضه قويه
وبان اردوغان خسرت مع كل ما عددناه سواء
في مقدمه هذا الملف او ما ذكره كذلك ضيفنا
في عدد ملفات خسر شعبيته وبالتالي قد يخسر
الانتخابات القادمه
تحياتي للجميع في البدايه من دون شك هناك
معارض للمره الاولى في تاريخ تركيا تتوحد
لسحبه بساط من تحت اقدام الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان لكن نستطيع ان نقول بان الرئيس
اردوغان الى حتى هذه اللحظه ما زال منافسا
قويا صعبا يحظى بدعم شريحه واسعه من
الشارع التركي نعم هذه المره نتحدث عن
تقارب في النسب في الايام الاخيره كانت
هناك المعارضه او السيد كمال كونه هو
متقدم ولكن بدانا نتحدث منذ ايام قليله
بانه هناك النسب اصبحت متقاربه والحديث
ايضا عن تسريبات يعني سوف يتم الاعلان
عنها من قبل الحكومه التركيه خلال الايام
المقبله هناك من يقول يوم الثلاثاء او
الاربعاء يعني في الساعه الاخيره او في
الوقت الضائع كما يقولون من عمر
الانتخابات المتبقيه تقريبا اسبوع من الان
لذا انا اتصور اعتقد ان هذه المنافسه هي
صعبه
الغايه خاصه ان كلا الطرفين ان كان
اردوغان او كريستال يريد الحصول او حسم
الموضوع من الجوله الاولى لكن حتى لحظه
نستطيع ان نقول الامور ليست
بالسهله هناك نقطه اخرى مهمه
تفضل تفضل باختصار نعم تفضل يعني هناك
نقطه مهمه وهي متعلقه بالشريحه المحافظين
المترددين اعت
قد مفتاح الفوز في هذه الانتخابات صحيح
وهي تراجعت بحسب استطلاعات الراي الاخيره
المراه خاصه ولكن اسمح لي ان اغير
السؤال او في غير مصلحتها ان يستمر
اردوغان في الحكم سيد طه
يعني حاليا اذا تحدثنا يعني كمواطنين
اتراكنا هناك من يريد التغيير حقيقه وخاصه
نتحدث عن جي 6 مليون شخص من الشباب هم لم
يروا الانجازات التي تحققت خلال عقدين
الماضيين راوا خلال تقريبا العوامل
الاربعه هناك
الازمه الاقتصاديه الاوضاع يعني الصعبه في
تركيا
انا اود قراءتك ورايك فيما يخص هذا
الموضوع انت كمواطن تركي
تحدثنا عن انتخابات وفهمنا من خلالك ومن
خلال كذلك الاستاذ جواد بانه هناك تنافس
وسيكون ستكون هذه الانتخابات تاريخيه ولكن
من خلالك انت هل في صالح تركيا ان يستمر
اردوغان ان يستمر حزبه ام ان هناك رياحا
جديده قادره ان تضفي المزيد من الجديد على
تركيا
يعني انا من ناحيه وجهه نظري مع غياب
الرئيس اردوغان في هذه الاوقات اعتقد
تركيا سوف ترجع الى الثمانينات القرن
الماضيه مع الرئيس اردوغان في ظل الاوضاع
الملتهبه في الاقليم بشكل كبير هي في
اتجاه التقدم وهذا ما تبعناه خلال الفتره
الاخيره في الازمه الروسيه والاوكرانيه
وايضا حاليا فيما يتعلق بموضوع الاقتصاد
ان اردوغان هو وعد الجميع بانه هو الشخص
الوحيد الذي قام يعني تحسين الاقتصاد خلال
السنوات الماضيه نعم الوضع الاقتصادي هو
ازمه عالميه ومن الممكن يعني تجاوز هذه
المرحله خلال الايام او الفتره المقبله
تضخم ارتفعت في تركيا بنسبه 85% في اكتوبر
سيد طه ولكن حضرتك يعني تقول او الفت الى
موضوع قلت بانه اذا لم يكن اردوغان القادم
فتركيا ستعود الى الثمانينات ما رايك سيد
جواد
لا ليس كذلك بالنتيجه
المواطن بشكل عادي يريد التغيير بعد 20
سنه هذا الامر امر عادي جدا راينا في
الديكتاتوريات السابقه في زمن حرب
العالميه الثانيه ماذا قال هتلر انه او
باقي الديكتاتوريات لو انا اذهب سيدمرون
البلد وغير ذلك لا بلد ثمانون مليون خمسه
وثمانون مليون نسمه يمشي بقوه لا يكون اي
شيء اي خطر على الامن القومي التركي
المواطنون نشاطات جدا البلد ولو ان الرئيس
اردوغان يفوز سوف نحترم هذه النتيجه
بالنتيجه لكن اذا يفوز كمال كلشتار اوغلو
المعارضه لا يكون البلد يعني يرجع الى
عشرين سنه ثلاثين سنه الى السابق لا ليس
كذلك البلد متطور ديمقراطيه لا زالت تشتغل
والان نحن نثق الى النظام الانتخابي لا
يوجد اي تزوير في الانتخابات في تركيا
بشكل شفافيه كلنا املنا صناديق الاقتراع
فنحن سوف نقترع اذا
كما قد اشتروا يفوز يكون نتيجته ايجابيه
جدا لتقدم البلد اكثر لتطوير البلد
اقتصاديا والسيا في العلاقات مع اشقائنا
العربي والاوروبي وغير ذلك لكن اذا فاز
اردوغان بصراحه
قضيه الاقتصاديه سوف تكون اصعب بكثير لكن
الشعب التركي الان قرارهم كما قال ضيفكم
شعبيه اردوغان لا زالت موجوده اتبعهم
اليوم كان لهم اجتماع لكن بشكل عام راينا
انه خاصه مع وجود حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي
والاكراد عندما اعلنوا دعمهم للمعارضه هذا
غيرت هذا الامر غير المعادلات السياسيه
هنا كما فازوا في الانتخابات المحليه
الاخيره كيف كسبوا كل المدن الساحليه
الغربيه الان مدن الشرقيه ايضا التحقوا
الى المعارضه بصراحه في هذه المره الفوز
مع المعارضه اكثر كما نرى
سيد طه ما رايك اولا تعليقك على كلام ضيفي
قبل سؤال مقبل لانه استشعرت وكانك لا
توافق ما تفضل به من قراءه
يعني هو السيد كمال يتحدث خلال الايام
الاخيره الماضيه بانه سوف يمنع الاجانب من
شراء العقارات سوف يمنع يعني فيما يتعلق
بالصناعات الدفاعيه وهذا ما اشرت لك قبل
قليل هذا رجوع تركيا للقرن الماضي هذا ما
قصدته خاصه تتذكرين في تلك الفتره كانت
تركيا هي بلد العسكر او الجيش كانت هي
كسكنه عسكريه ولكن عندما وصل حزب العداله
والتنميه الى سلطه في عام 2002 كانت هناك
نهضه اقتصاديه في البلاد وكانت هناك يعني
علاقات كبيره مع دول عربيه وعدد دول من
دول العالم وفيما يتعلق بموضوع ما بعد
اردوغان اذا فاز اردوغان على التصور اعتقد
السياسه التركيه سياسه الرئيس اردوغان سوف
تكون مختلفه عما تابعناه وشاهدناه قبل
عامين كانت هناك دفاع تركيا في الاقليم
ولكن العامين المقبلين سوف يكون التركيز
بشكل كبير على موضوع الداخله التركي
والاقتصاد التركي لان
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ومع مصر وهذه هي
سياسه جديده اتبعناها في تركيا على خلاف
ما تبعناه خلال الاشهر الاخيره الماضيه
البعض يقول سيد جواد كذلك في هذا الاطار
بان هناك وكان اشكاليه في اختيار منافس
اردوغان كمال كلتش قد لا يكون الانسب ببعض
حتى في داخل التركي تحدث عن كاريزما
الرئيس عن تاريخه عن ما يمكن ان يقدمها هل
تعتقد بانه
قادر ان يكون منافس قوي لا اتحدث عن
الاحزاب مجتمعه اتحدث عن الشخص بالتحديد
اردوغان شخصيه قويه جدا يعني
كان يعني انا اقول بصراحه كان سياسته في
السنه في العشر سنوات الاولى كانت قويه
جدا مهما بدات قضيه الربيع العربي والتدخل
في شؤون سوريا الداخليه وفي شؤون مصر
الداخليه
يعني راينا انه يعني مهما يصل الرجل الى
القوه كلما يزيد في القوه ينقص من
العقلانيه والحكمه هذا الذي راينا هنا في
تركيا مع الاسف الشديد في الاونه الاخيره
كانت سياساته خاطئه مع الاسف مثلا بالنسبه
الى سوريا كانت سياسته خاطئه جدا يعني
وجاء اربع ملايين سوريين الى هنا وزادت
المشاكل الاقتصاديه والقوميات تطرفت وغير
ذلك اذا كانت هذه السياسات خاطئه الان
يريد ان يصحي هذه الاخطاء مثلا بالنسبه
الى دوله مصر لماذا تدخلنا الى شؤون مصر
الداخليه يعني هل
يلزم لنا ان نرجح مصلحه بلدنا على مصلحه
الحزب او ايديولوجي
شخصيه اردوغان لكن ماذا عما يهم شخصيه
منافس اردوغان اتحدث على كمال كالجدار
اوغلو
انسان معتدل جدا جدا معتدل ولسانه معتدل
لا ياتي بتصريحات ناريه اعلاميه وغير لا
يتكلم استهلاكيه
لكن
بالنتيجه هو في المعارضه
يتهمونه انه ماذا فعلتم ماذا يقدر يفعل
بالنتيجه ليست الحكومه بيده ان نعطي له
حظا
ان نرى يعني السياسهم اذا ما يكونوا
ناجحين سوف نختار الشخص اخر او حزب اخر
وغير ذلك بالنتيجه لابد ان نعطي له حظا في
الانتخابات القادمه هذا الذي يقوله
المواطنون في تركيا سيد طه ضيف منذ قليل
استمعت لا تحدث عن موضوع اللجوء الى
الداخل التركي هل هذا الموضوع قادر ان
يؤثر على نسب الانتخاب وعلى
الناخب على مزاج الناخب ان صح التعبير ام
يبقى موضوع ثانوي
موضوع لجوء السوريين تقصدين صحيح
نعم يعني هذه يعني هذه كان موضوع كان
سابقا كانت هي ورقه كبيره لدى المعارضه
التركيه وحتى المعارضه خلال الايام
الاخيره الماضيه تم الحديث عن هذا الموضوع
لكن انا اتصور اعتقد هناك يعني موضوع
مواضيع اهم وهي موضوع الازمه الاقتصاديه
والوضع الاقتصادي لاحظتي خلال الخطابات
والحملات الانتخابيه لكلا زعيمين كان
يتحدثا عن تطمينات للشارع التركي فيما
يتعلق بالرواتب فيما يتعلق يعني غلاء
المعيشه فيما يتعلق يعني هناك يعني
التطمينات كلها هذه هي النقطه الاساسيه
التي تهم الشارع التركي بالدرجه الاولى
موضوع اللاجئين اعتقد هو يبقى موضوع جانب
ولكن يبقى هناك القلق يساوي هؤلاء
اللاجئين وخاصه بعد التصريحات التي صدرت
من احزاب متطرفه كحزب النصر هنا الذي وعد
باعاده اللاجئين في اليوم الثاني في
الخامس عشر من مايو الجاري وايضا واتحدث
سوف يقوم باعادتهم خلال عامين هذا ليس من
السهل اذا تحدثنا من ناحيه قانون من ناحيه
قانونيه ولكن هي في في اطار التصريحات
الاستهلاكيه والانتخابيه
وتفاصيلها وشكركم جزيل الشكر من اسطنبول
الكتب والمحلل السياسي والشكر كذلك
الحظرتك جواد جورج المحلل السياسي شكرا
لكم
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات